There's a
new controversy
tonight involving
Supreme Court Justice Clarence Thomas.
ProPublica is now reporting
in an in-depth story
that for more than two decades,
Justice Thomas and his wife,
Ginni Thomas,
have secretly accepted luxury trips
from the billionaire Republican donor,
Harlan Crow.
These trips include flights
on his private jet
cruising on his super yacht,
also going to far flung places
like a trip in Indonesia.
Sales in 19,
as well as trips
to an exclusive All-Male retreat
in California.
That's known as the Bohemian Grove.
Josh Caplan
is one of the ProPublica
reporters who broke this story.
And luckily,
he joins us now at this table.
This story is kind of rocked
the not just New York of
Washington, Phil, as well.
I think you would agree.
Tell us what your reporting found.
Yes.
So we
found that Clarence Thomas has
been taking luxury trips
from a billionaire real estate
magnate and Republican Megadonor
virtually every year for over 20 years.
And as as you said, private jet
flights around the world,
international yacht
cruises
regular trips to a private resort,
invitation only, you know,
staffed by private chefs.
The Indonesia trip,
you mentioned
he this is in 2019
just one recent example
he flew Thomas flew on the billionaire's
private jet
to Indonesia
and spent
nine days island
hopping on a super yacht
staff by you know with a full staff
the day after the court finished its term
that couple of days
a couple of days
and yeah if we were told that
if Thomas had chartered that itself
it would have cost at least $500,000,
$500,000.
It's a it's a nice private jet.
But that's not how you travel.
That is not how I roll at all.
So this ethics related to Supreme
Court has been kind
of a bubbling issue in Congress
for a number of years now.
There are some bills
that have already been proposed.
I think your story is probably
going to lose a few more,
to say the least.
But can you explain to people why
even the parts that
I think right now are up in the air
as to whether or not
they were legal or problematic?
Why Supreme Court
justices could do something like this,
not have to report it
and have nobody know were it
not for your investigation?
Yes.
So, I mean,
I think one of the root issues here
is that
Supreme Court justices face
very little transparency
and very little oversight compared to
essentially every other member
of the federal government
where, you know, I mean, for instance,
while it is experts told us that appears
to violated
the law, that he didn't
disclose these trips,
there are no restrictions, really,
or there are few restrictions
on what gifts justices can accept.
And that's a really stark contrast
from the other branches of government.
So, you know,
essentially, I
mean, the Supreme Court has for a while
been left
to almost entirely to police itself.
You know what I find interesting?
Lower courts can be policed,
if you will, by Congress,
because Congress can post
ethics rules on lower courts.
The Supreme Court
is deemed
and put in place by the Constitution
and nobody has a rules of ethics
at the Supreme.
Let me say that again.
The Supreme Court,
the highest court in the land.
It literally
it blows my mind
to think about that, that
there are no rules
that they have decided among themselves.
They could say, listen,
we have got to have something in place.
If for nothing else,
then the word legitimacy,
because everyone is worried
about all of the different problems
with sort of the government
and whether or not
they're going to see this quarter
any further court as a legitimate court.
If they can't police themselves,
why are they police or not?
Well, this this goes to,
you know, the founders and the framers.
They recognize
that you have to have what they call
Republican virtues,
not capital or Republican,
but virtues
that support having a republic, having
the rule of law, having democracy.
And they didn't think
that you would actually
have to tell people
not to take $500,000 of like,
you know, fund trips and not report on it
because there was
this idea that you would have virtues
along side of the words
that are written down.
And one of the things I think
is really interesting
is that when you hear
from Clarence Thomas,
when he speaks, he speaks so much about
virtues, ethics, morality, etc.
It's his main grievance
against the country
that people are getting away
from those values.
And yet in his own life,
he's not practicing the values
of transparency, of ethical conduct.
And so it causes a real,
I think, problem for the country
when they are not policing themselves.
And in fact, they are
yelling at the rest of us for doing stuff
they're not doing on their own.
What's what's the defense
that you're hearing from
Clarence Thomas
or the Supreme Court on this?
So Clarence Thomas,
we sent him detailed questions,
follow up repeatedly.
He didn't respond.
So we haven't heard from Thomas,
but the his friend, the billionaire
Harlan Crow,
told us they're very dear friends.
And, you know,
he acknowledged
that his extended hospitality
to Thomas over the years, but said, No.
One, that Thomas hadn't
asked for any of it.
And also that it was no different
than what he's extended
to his many other dear friends.
Can I just quickly ask,
was there any case that you found
where
perhaps there was a conflict of interest
that Clarence Thomas looked
at that involved
any business dealings with his
his friend, his very wealthy friend?
Yeah, I mean,
so Caro has never personally
had a case before the Supreme Court.
Most people don't, or at least not
very often
he but I mean,
but he does have vast
financial and ideological interests.
So he's one he is a enormously
successful business figure.
And also he's
given millions of dollars
to ideological efforts
to shape the judiciary, to shape the law,
including the Federalist Society.
You know, he's
also he sits on the board of major
think tanks that publish
conservative legal scholarship
that's advancing specific theories.
Their scholars
occasionally file
amicus briefs to the Supreme Court.
So it's a complicated question.
And it's
I also should note that, you know,
he's given ten you know,
over $10 million in disclosed donations.
But we know he's also
given to dark money groups.
And so it's
you know, to a certain extent,
there's an unknown there, safe to say.
I mean, Clarence
Thomas is no stranger to scrutiny.
Neither is his wife.
And safe to say
this is only adding to it.
Josh Kaplan, thanks for your reporting
and thanks for sharing it with us today.
Thanks so much for having me.
The other remarkable story
we're talking about this morning
is this ProPublica report
into Supreme Court Justice
Clarence Thomas
and these luxury trips
that he and
his wife
took with a Republican megadonor,
which the donor says
that was just hospitality.
It wasn't anything that Justice
Thomas had asked for.
Justice Thomas himself has not commented
and there's no formal code of conduct
at the Supreme Court
that would bar him from doing this.
But I wonder if this makes
you think there needs to be
tighter restrictions
on the ethics code
for someone like a Supreme Court justice?
Well, first of all, I
don't know if the facts of the report,
the reporting is accurate.
I assume it is, but parts of
it may not be accurate.
And it and I know Justice Thomas,
I talked with a lot of people,
hard people that would know him
extremely well.
I don't think this kind of action
would in any way influence
his decision on the court.
But having said all that,
I worry about the image,
the fact that a justice's
is taking these gifts
and not reporting it
if, in fact, the law requires reporting.
And if the reason you don't report
is because you're afraid of how it looks,
maybe you shouldn't accept it.
Again, I don't think it has any influence
or impact
on the work of the justice,
but I think it's creates further
angst about the court,
about the justices.
Obviously, given the recent decisions
at the end of the last term,
a lot of people have raised questions
about about the court
talks about expanding,
the court talks about term
limits, talk about limiting
the jurisdiction of the court.
So I think the
justices need to be careful
because it's not all about
just your individual conduct.
Whatever you do, whatever you say,
it affects the rest of the justices.
It affects the reputation of the court.
And I think if you look at recent polling
and the judges generally should,
I would say, urge them
not to look at recent polling
because they need to make their decisions
based on what they believe
is right, believe
based upon what the Constitution
or the statutes say.
But nonetheless,
you need to be sensitive
about how your actions affect how people
believe or respect the court
because in the end, respect
respecting the judgment of the court
depends upon how people view the court.